Speaker 1: So I present to you with peace and love
and a word of warning. The latest FiveThirtyEight
estimates for the Senate and for the House for
these midterm elections. Now, there are so many
different caveats and important things to talk
about. But let me give you the numbers first in
the Senate. The FiveThirtyEight forecast now
puts it at a 68% chance that Democrats hold
control of the Senate. That is greater than a
2 to 1 margin. Now, things that are 32% likely
to happen happen all the time. So so we can't
count out Republicans in the Senate. It is 68
to 32 in terms of likelihood of controlling the
Senate. Based on the FiveThirtyEight forecast over
in the House. It is a 24% chance that Democrats
hold the House of Representatives. It's roughly,
we could say, a 3 to 1 margin by which Republicans
are expected to hold the House. Now, I want to
remind you guys, this doesn't mean Republicans
are expected to hold 76% of the seats. In fact,
not at all. It's expected to be a relatively small
margin if Republicans win. But Republicans are
favored to win the House by any margin by roughly
3 to 1. Now, there are many important things to
talk about here. First and foremost, both of
these numbers, the Democratic odds in the Senate
and the Democratic odds in the House have been
climbing over time. You might remember that some
months ago on the Senate side, it was like a
52% chance that Democrats were going to hold
the Senate. That's basically a coin flip that has
steadily climbed and climbed and climbed. It got
to 2 to 1 a few days ago and it has now gone
beyond 2 to 1. So the momentum is absolutely
there in terms of Democrats now. They're not
going to get 60 seats. Democrats are not going
to get 60 seats. So in some sense, it's kind
of an academic question whether Democrats,
if they do hold the Senate, will have somewhere
between a 5050 majority with Kamala Harris as
the 51st tie breaking vote, up to some number
under 60 senators. 60 is important because
there are some measures in the Senate where you
need 60 votes. A simple majority isn't enough.
Democrats are not going to get 65. I don't see
any path for that. So it is almost certainly going
to be a situation where in order to get things
done, Democrats on many issues are going to need
some Republican votes. Obviously, it's better
to only need four Republican votes than ten.
No doubt about that. But that's where we're
kind of operating, a very narrow margin now
over in the House. When you just look at the House
numbers and you see, oh, man, that three, two,
one margin Republicans are expected to hold
just a couple of months ago, the Democratic
Democratic odds were far lower. I think they were
around 16, 17 or 18%. So the shift from 17 to 24
in terms of the sheer raw numbers is
not significant. But seven over 17,
you're talking about a roughly 40% increase in the
odds that Democrats hold still favored to lose.
But a significant change. What isn't reflected
in these numbers? Democratic overperformance
and Democratic electorate overrepresentation. In
other words, turnout. And what we have seen now
in Michigan and in New York and in Alaska is that
the polls did not reflect a correct weighting on
the basis of Democratic enthusiasm. And we've
talked before about a number of the different
reasons for this enthusiasm. Part of it includes,
yes, the overturning of Roe v Wade by this right
wing Supreme Court. Part of it includes Republican
inaction on gun safety, although over the last
month, that's probably faded a little bit in
people's minds. And the very dramatic shift in
all of a sudden, the MAGA right is in massive
legal trouble. Trump might be getting indicted,
Republicans, civil war, all of these different
things. And on the on the Democratic side,
things are quite calm. Joe Biden is racking up
legislative accomplishments. The Pact Act. The
Inflation Reduction Act. Infrastructure. A very
good jobs report. We are essentially at full
employment. Wages are up. Inflation is down. Gas
prices are down. And all of a sudden, there are
people who are saying, what is the choice here?
A party in disarray, soon facing indictments.
The Republican Party or Joe Biden, who has very
quietly gotten a bunch of things done, student
loan debt forgiveness now coming, people talking
about maybe something on cannabis, etc., etc.,
that is not reflected in the numbers. And so while
historically this should be a very bad election
for Democrats, it's increasingly looking less
and less bad. We're going to continue following
the numbers and I hope you'll join me tonight,
roughly 7 p.m. Eastern for Joe Biden's address to
the nation. I think it will be very interesting. I
will be live on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook. And
of course, you can follow me on Twitter at David
Pakman. Let me know what you make of these numbers